now before we begin here I would just like to address something once and for all people have been insinuating that the only reason that I do this show is so that I can bring out a beautiful women and talk to them every single day and obviously nothing could be further from the truth before we begin roaming can I get your glass of Malbec I would love that that is great and fellows seem seems a little bright here to do an interview so okay yeah that's a lot better that is much better so what let's just dig right into this interview roaming what's your sign our cancer you're kidding yeah that is such a coincidence I also have an astrological sign oh my gosh no way [Music] Cheers [Music] so what uh what is your favorite color M&M why don't we both say our favorite colors on the count of three okay that sounds fine one two three red it's just like something's happening here yeah definitely how's your fiancee [Music] you